Jaylen that looked like a prize fight
how did that
feel that was fun that
was that was fun that was
fun the night started with you being
named to your first allar
game just talk about the journey you've
been on and how it has reached this
point now where you're on the garden
floor hearing MVP chance and you're
going to the all-star game I
[Applause]
mean I got I got nothing to say I got
nothing to say all right then talk about
your teammates cuz I know you will you
guys are short-handed playing this game
this is a tough game this is a big
Eastern Conference game what did you see
out of this group where mainly seven
guys played but yet fought back from
down 15 to win so we got fighting man I
mean no matter what we're going to keep
fighting that's what we
do going to keep fighting every single
night that's what we do especially here
man this place is unbelievable
especially here congratulations Jaylen
thank you so much fight Mike is the
appropo word
tonight thank you Alan